Hi, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness. Today, we're in Ezekiel.
Ezekiel 36. All right. We're going backwards,
actually, into the Old Testament.
We've done a lot of New Testament metaphors for holiness, and
today, we are going back into the Old Testament and grabbing a
metaphor from Ezekiel 36. Now, I
know that this passage of scripture I'm about to read to
you was written about God's physical,
ethnic people, Israel. So those descended from
Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob physically.
However, it is important to know that in the relationship that
God's people, Christians through Christ, have with Israel,
that we have been grafted into the
people of God, and that we are recipients of
some of those promises in advance of the rest of them.
All right? So spiritual realities that God promises to Israel,
not concerning land, and we're not heirs of the
land of Israel over in the Middle East, and all of that.
But there are spiritual realities God promises to us because we
are his people by faith like Abram was by faith. All right?
So
some of these realities God has brought to pass in our lives now, and
we'll talk about that as we go along. All right.
So we're going to start in Ezekiel 36, and we're going to start with verse number
25. All right? "And I will sprinkle clean water
on you, and you will be clean.
I will cleanse you from all your impurities and from
your idols." Now, this is a significant concept in the Book
of Ezekiel and really all through the Old Testament.
But in Ezekiel specifically,
Ezekiel uses the word in a very particular way that I want
to draw out. So in our way of thinking, a lot
of times an idol can be like a statue. Right?
Something in the corner of somebody's living room or a shrine or some
temple in a third world country somewhere.
But Ezekiel uses the word in a very interesting way, particularly in
Ezekiel 14:3, when he
talks about those who have taken their idols
into their hearts. Now, that's very fascinating
because what it communicates to us is that idols are
not just external things that live out there in the corner of
somebody's life, somebody's living room, and they're burning incense to it.
An idol can be anything that we take into our heart
that becomes something that we expect to give us
that which only God can give us.
So joy, satisfaction, identity, peace,
protection, security, hope.
You get the idea.
Something that is a good thing, perhaps, even a good thing, that
becomes a God thing, and that's a bad thing. Right?
That's idolatry in the idea of the scripture, and the
idea, specifically, of Ezekiel. So he talks about those that
take their idols into their hearts, and he says, "I'm going to cleanse you."
This is important then. So Ezekiel, who says idols have been taken
into their hearts of the people, also says he's going to cleanse
them. God says he's going to cleanse those people from all of their
idols, even the idols of the heart.
"I will give you a new heart and put a new spirit within
you. I will remove from you your heart of stone and give you a heart of flesh."
So no more hard heart, a soft heart instead.
And he says, "I will put my spirit within you and move you to
follow my decrees and be careful to keep my
laws."
Now,
when Ezekiel talks about all this, he's giving us this beautiful
picture that
is going to take place for the nation of Israel
sometime, right? But though he's not going to bring us
back to the land, which is what he gets into next, and he's not going
to
make our harvests of grain plentiful necessarily in this time, though
he sometimes does, we're grateful for that. Right?
But he's saying that some of these
promises that God has made in the New Covenant, we have the
privilege of reaching out as God's people of faith.
We have the privilege of reaching out and bringing into the present
some of these covenant promises which God has given to his people,
and this is one of those. We get to reach out and say, "By God's
grace, I choose to appropriate the
promise of God to give me a clean heart now, and to give me
a soft heart instead of a hard one, and to give me a heart
that is careful to follow everything
that God has asked of me." Now,
this is the reason I say that this has not yet come to pass for Israel
because God did regather them into the land after captivity, didn't
he? Right? And he did bless them
in many ways, didn't he?
But did he take all of their idols out of their heart?
No.
No, they stopped chasing after
the gods of other nations in some ways, yes.
But they literally took the law of Moses in religion, in truth, in
morality itself, as good as those things are
when they're used lawfully,
they took those things into their heart and made them an idol.
Isn't that remarkable? John Calvin said the human heart is an idol
factory. We manufacture something to worship,
something to trust in, and something to rest in.
It's a remarkable idea that we can be in our hearts,
even great and beautiful and right and good things can become
substitutes for God.
But we have the opportunity.
You and I have the opportunity, by the power of the Holy Spirit
dwelling within us, that God has made available through the
giving of the Holy Spirit and what Jesus talked about in Acts
2, the Holy Spirit is poured out, and wow,
we get the opportunity to receive now
that which God has promised to his people in the long term, and that's
tremendous. So I would encourage you to take this
metaphor and say, "This one's mine.
I'm going to make this part of my goal, part of my
life right now. I'm going to bring some of those future kingdom
realities into now, and I want to have a heart
where God does that for me."
There's an incredible verse of poetry written by John Newton.
Many of you would know "Amazing Grace," which was written by him, but there's
another verse of poetry that pictures this so
beautifully. He says, "Dear Lord, the idol self
dethrone, and from our hearts remove, and
let no zeal by us be shown, but that which
springs from love."
Now, John Newton and John Wesley may not have
agreed theologically on everything, but that could've been written by
either one because that's the hunger and the thirst of the people of
God. Oh, Lord, the ultimate idol self that corrupts
all the other ones, that corrupted sin nature that when it rules over any
good thing, communicates its corruption to that good thing.
Oh, Lord, the idol self dethrone, and
from my heart remove. So I want to encourage you, take that
metaphor and make it yours today. God bless you.
We'll see you tomorrow.